the helicopter was bringing troops to a
government checkpoint when rebels shot
it down 160 kilometers from the russian
border the government in kiev vowed the
rebels would not go unpunished there is
i am confident our armed forces and
security agencies will flush out the
terrorists
all the criminals financed by the
russian federation will be destroyed or
will stand before a court
government fighter jets flying over
sloveon's going to show of force the
city remains under separatist control
pro-russian rebels say they're holding
four osce monitors who went missing
earlier in the week
at a press conference the city's
self-proclaimed mayor yayacha slav
ponamayoff said they'll soon be free
at present they are in the luhansk
region i spoke to the people who
detained the group
they have some questions for the osce
team
and when they get all the answers and
inspect all the team's gear the monitors
will be released
in donetsk some 100 kilometers south of
sloveonsk there's an atmosphere of tents
calm earlier this week heavy fighting
around the city's airport left dozens
dead the separatists say they'll use
force again if provoked
i hope kiev decides against bringing
troops into the city the city is already
surrounded by them that's enough
if they want a war it'll be a bloodbath
on both sides
separatists are erecting fresh
barricades all over donetsk
russia has called on kiev to start a
national dialogue with the rebels to
avert what it called a national
catastrophe